[Music]
it's alleged that a gang of child
abusers is at large in the city of hull
he decided it was time to pay for the
presents they'd bought me
and that payment
was in sex
but prosecutions for sexual attacks in
the uk fail too often and it's the same
for the young women we'll meet in this
case
multiple allegations
no convictions
but what does it take to charge alleged
sex offenders it is of course the victim
who carries the burden of proof
[Music]
so how did you feel when they met to
tell you that the police investigation
was closed
i went a bit crazy in this meeting
because i was really upset but they said
there's no further investigations they
can do they've got everything we can't
go any further because the lack of
evidence but
there is evidence there
you see the one there
yep that's the one
in this series of reports we will
present some of the evidence starting
with sarah's story
that room that flat
took my childhood from me
i think i was raped by around 150 men
over the three year period
they were coming in sometimes 10 or 11
men wanted to rape me per day
13 year old sarah was escaping
difficulties at home when she was
groomed by two men who brought her food
and presents but after two months one of
them raped her then he brought her to
this block of flats
he'd obviously decided that i was a good
enough candidate to take to the next
level and introduced me to this other
guy and exchanged some money with this
other guy
so later found out i was sold into the
sex trade
experts have told us gang members can
get paid to groom girls in this way in a
spider graph sarah later made for the
police she identifies 11 key players who
came to the flat the two groomers the
buyer and other regular abusers she
numbers them and provides photos which
we've obviously blurred this is a
drawing of herself
height four foot six neon pink leggings
mickey mouse t-shirt this items in the
flat used to intimidate and control a
taser hammer and handcuffs
how did he persuade you to keep coming
back
i had to go
he threatened me
and as a young 13 year old girl being
told you're going to be buried alive and
set on fire it's scary we have a text
exchange from one of the men in 2018
that sarah photographed on her phone
where have you been you lose money for
us i'm sorry i got into trouble where i
live
lots of men who sex with you asking for
you they want a white
i'm not a yes you are
he insisted you come immediately you
know what will happen if you don't we
put you in a van and beat you and take
you to hessel foreshore and burn you
while awake then bury you near water
okay i'll come
good
sarah and other alleged victims told us
this beauty spot of hessel foreshore is
one of the places men took them to
sexually abuse them but it mostly
happened in flats or hotels and was
sometimes filmed
these videos out there of me as 13 14 15
year old little girl being raped by men
i've seen them they've shown me them
one of the videos he's captioned english
girl gets against her own will and i was
just profit to them
you know sexually assaulted physically
assaulted
throughout this investigation we'll be
showing our evidence to one of the uk's
leading child exploitation experts
former chief police officer jim gamble
gave us his view of the threatening text
well number one is he's committed to
criminal offence because that's a threat
to murder and the offences against the
persons act makes that a crying but what
you do see there is the coercive control
you see the fact that the predator is so
confident
in their ability
their level of competence at controlling
these young people that they don't even
try and hide it or mask it i'd be
surprised if they're not able to pass
the evidential threshold because what
you do have is you have significant
levels of corroboration
humberside police arrested 34 suspects
and say they did digital searches on 150
devices seized and the phone records
didn't provide supporting evidence they
couldn't confirm the origin of the
threatening text and didn't reach the
evidence threshold to go to court
but what about corroboration there are
other alleged victims in this case
i met anna when i was in foster care and
i didn't know she was involved she
didn't know i was involved but one day
she saw my name on one of the men's
phones
anna tells sarah about someone we'll
call man a the same man who allegedly
sent the threatening text to sarah and
they both admit to being raped by him he
had his hands around my throat and let
go when i was literally about to die
admit sarah in a text yes same says anna
i couldn't breathe when he did it i
couldn't even scream he had my neck so
tight
anna then texted a long list of abusers
some of whom sarah recognized and i
reported it to the police she saw my
name on his phone she knew what he was
like she knew what he'd done to her
[Music]
a third woman also told us about
allegations against man a but in our
next report we will meet anna who has
collated a whole dossier of evidence the
police knew what was going on like my
mum was reporting me missing sometimes
three times a day
[Music]
delving into this case doesn't just
expose how one group of women couldn't
get charges it perhaps explains why
fewer than two percent of alleged rape
victims in the uk get their day in court
jason farrell sky news
[Music]